hi everyone i'm nicole forsgren and
thank you so much for joining us at the
developer velocity and productivity
panel we have a fantastic group of
speakers joining us and i will let them
introduce themselves as soon as i say a
little bit about myself so as i
mentioned i'm nicole i am a partner at
microsoft research and i have spent the
last
many many years investigating things
like software development delivery
productivity and how to make folks
better at developing and delivering
software across teams across geographies
across any type of industry vertical so
margaret do you introduce yourself
yes uh hi everybody i'm margaret anstory
from the university of victoria i'm a
professor there in computer science and
uh like nicole i've been studying
developer productivity for oh about the
past 20 years
first looking at how tools could
automate architecture recovery from
legacy tools our legacy systems
them when i observed developers i
realized that many of the assumptions i
had about them were wrong so then i
turned to doing studies of developers
and during the past few years i've been
investigating developer productivity
developer satisfaction as well as how
developers collaborate through social
and communication media and more
recently looking at how developers work
from home during the pandemic
great thanks amanda
my name is amanda silver i run the
developer division at microsoft and so
we work on all of the products that are
focused on developers as the customers
i've been at microsoft for the last 20
years now
and our products basically are kind of
everything that a developer uses every
day visual studio visual studio code a
lot of the programming languages and
runtimes that a lot of developers use
like net or typescript things like that
but you know a lot of my passion goes to
developer productivity i'm just really
inspired by developers i love having
them as my customers
because they're tech enthusiasts and you
know if i release something in the
morning i can know by the end of the day
whether or not it's a hit or a dud so as
a product person i live for that kind of
feedback and it's just really awesome to
work for work on behalf of developers
great brian
wow um well i'm brian lyles and i'm
actually truly awed by the people who
are on this panel with me right now wow
um so i am a principal engineer at
vmware
when it comes to developer productivity
i like to say that i like to be lazy so
anything about optimizing productivity
is is about where i am but as my career
has gone it's gone from you know
optimizing profitability for myself to
now where i think about how do i
optimize productivity for you know 10 or
15 or 20 000 developers
so i'm deeply interested not a scientist
but more of a practitioner
that is a perfect introduction and segue
brian thank you so i'm excited about
this group because when i was thinking
about productivity velocity and for
developers i really kind of wanted to
get a mix of some of my favorite people
and favorite smart thinkers
that spanned research but also real
world practice so we could talk about
what we see what we think and so now i'm
up to my first question um
why is developer productivity something
that you pay attention to in your work
or is it right so what are the things
that you think about would you ignore it
when do you really pay attention to it
um brian let's start with you
okay so what i thought about this
because i knew this question was coming
and one of the things i think about
constantly is
uh not doing too much you know you can
go ahead and try to uh optimize all
everything away to to get that place of
productivity but what happens whenever
you change one thing or change two
things
so now what i think about is um with
everything that i do is this does this
give me joy it's the marie kondo way of
looking at this give me joy okay well i
can deal with this so i don't worry
about it but if it doesn't give me joy i
also think well how many other people is
this affecting is affecting 10 100 1 000
10 thousand
and so
the ways that i'm thinking about it now
are like huge um company-wide
initiatives of like how can i make you
know how can i not be a 1x developer or
a 10x developer how can i be a 10 10 000
x developer i know people won't like
this but
i'm really thinking about ways to make a
group of individuals and teams work
better constantly
so yeah i think about it all the time
that's great um
margaret what do you think about how do
you think about this especially from
like a research standpoint yeah the uh
likewise i also knew this question was
coming and it's such a great question
and i had to think about why do i keep
why am i keep doing this topic why do i
keep caring about developer productivity
and i think um actually the point about
joy really struck me there as well
because that's something that artie
starr talks about in her book called
flow and artie sarah also mentions she's
described software developers as the
magicians of the world
they bring ideas and they bring hardware
to life and so as a researcher i study
developers because i don't just get to
study the magic of the tools and the
technologies that we're building but i
also get to study the craft of how
developer magicians individually and as
a community create this magic and the
other reason i guess is that it's never
boring so during my career we've had
numerous paradigm shifts okay you know
the internet was before i started but
only just um but you know higher line
level languages
integrated tools devops
and social tools like stack overflow and
github so it continues to fascinate me
and it continues to change so yeah and
also in research there isn't enough
focus on the human and social aspects i
have to say
i really love that point um
so we've been talking about developer
productivity and
i think that in and of itself is sort of
an interesting point right because
developer productivity is this term that
just gets thrown around a lot especially
when we think about the last
year or two
where we have found ourselves working
right so
we find ourselves in this heightened
tracking
and monitoring of work
now that people are doing even more work
from home than we used to do before
and
you know folks can't just walk down the
halls and see people working at their
desks and so i wonder how maybe how each
of us define developer productivity i'd
really like to start with you amanda
what do you think about this
yeah i think it's a it's a fantastic
question you know i think everything in
the context of the developer shortage
that we actually have right now right
there's huge demand for talent and the
bottom line is that there's more demand
for you know what could be created then
we have the capacity to actually build
and that's true on an individual team
level and it's true for the entire
industry as a whole
and so you know the way that i think
about things is how can we mint new
developers and kind of make them more
productive more quickly how can we make
individuals and teams more productive
and then how can we kind of you know
scale better through collaboration
whether that's collaboration with other
disciplines or it's collaboration you
know with the open source community for
example
and developers and other organizations
the bottom line to me is that it's
obviously not lines of code or like the
number of pr's merged or the number of
releases that you've you've done and as
a product person i'm very i'm a big
believer in kind of
customer driven metrics like customer
outcomes
right and as a in a way as an
engineering manager and i talked to a
lot of engineering managers in my day
job
you know what they they kind of have
like their developers on their team as
their customers right it's like how do
we think about their job satisfaction so
that they can have better retention over
time and like it's so important in the
context of the period that we're in
right now which you know a lot of people
have started to call the great
resignation we're just seeing a lot of
churn in the industry people looking for
new roles and so there's an absolute you
know talent war that's going on right
now
so i think you know you don't
necessarily want to look at individual
productivity you really want to kind of
focus more on the engineering system
that your team actually works in and so
it's things like how long does it take
for somebody to onboard onto the team
and to check in a meaningful feature or
to test a code change or to see the
change in production or the mean time to
remediation and kind of how to um you
know address those things and get that
out as quickly as possible
and so i think thinking in in terms of
the larger system in which everybody's
working
but i also think like you know obviously
a lot of that is inspired by the
research that that margaret and and
nicole have done
um
but also like i got very inspired by the
the good day research that you guys did
also uh nicole like maybe actually you
should you should talk about the good
day research that was just really great
work
sure um
maybe if that's okay i'll jump in a
little bit here um so i
i appreciate that that mentioned and i i
agree with you right it's not just about
how individuals do work it's not just
about
you know a few things it really is kind
of a holistic way of of looking at
productivity so some of the work that
you know margaret and i did earlier this
year looked at
a framework for assessing and thinking
about productivity
as an overall measure and so you know
one of the papers we put out was the
space framework and it says space i love
acronyms if anything because it helps me
remember things and so you know space is
it suggests that we look at productivity
holistically and like you said not just
lines of code
lines of code is nice because mostly
because it's easy to measure but it's
all that also means it's easy to gain so
space is you know five things s is
satisfaction and that can be individual
satisfaction or like you mentioned it
could be satisfaction with an
engineering system
p
is performance so that's an outcome
measure right so is it performance
through the system
um a is activity these are the things
that we're used to measuring is it it's
usually a count or a number so lines of
code number of pr's number of commits a
number of something um and then e is
efficiency and flow so this can be
did i feel like i was in the flow did it
feel like i was you know getting things
done it could be lack of interruptions
or it can be flow through the system
like a time metric
so that helps me even as a personal
check did i miss something am i not
thinking about something should i have
metrics that are in tension so that i
make sure that i'm not throwing things
out of whack by only measuring one thing
um and it helps me think about teams as
well
and then when i think about the good day
project that was a nice quick way for
individual developers to think about
how do i think about good days and a
bunch of this was inspired by some of my
colleagues work um
tom zimmerman and danny ford robinson
right and it was how do i manage my
energy and not my time because it really
is about having good days when i do my
work
um yeah it all kind of reminds me a lot
of you know paul graham's like
you know
original blog post many years ago around
the maker schedule versus the manager's
schedule and you know i think margaret
also kind of reflected that she's
inspired by developers because they're
creators
and i think one of the things that we
have to recognize is that developers are
creators they are makers and ultimately
you know they operate on the maker's
schedule and so you know what we need to
think about as managers
of of engineers
is is giving them the opportunity to get
into that flow and to maintain that flow
yeah
uh brian i'm curious to hear how
this kind of
like hits you and how this like hits
your brain because you're you're
managing so many different people and
and how you think about uh developer
productivity and that term in particular
yeah that term is is one of those
interesting terms so developer
productivity
um and then and then there's a couple
more in the same realm where you know
you you hear it and you're like well
what does that mean
so i will give you my spin on it before
i tell you my thoughts so i think about
um not all time sitting and typing on
the keyboard is productive
and that's something that a lot of
people don't understand that just
because you're sitting at the keyboard
and typing
that you are doing something that is
useful
as a vp level engineer at vmware you
know i'm actually kind of rare where um
i actually spent
almost a quarter of this week writing
software
and and that's and it's rare at this
level too
and i don't do it all the time and
because i just wanted to solve this very
hard problem
but i was thinking about as i was coding
and how productive am i
and when it's and it's like setting up
my environment i'm an expert at that my
environment set up um getting access to
software that i didn't write and being
able to see documentation and use apis
you know
you know our software of our software is
20 years old and some of it's hard to
use you know what a knock on
productivity i'm being able to share
what i built and learned with others you
know that's that's good for my
productivity and good for theirs and i'm
also thinking about those things and
then also um taking this proof of
concept because you know as a vp that's
really all i can write i can't write
production software anymore that's
liability but as as this poc that i've
written is it is it usable on other
people's machines
am i giving this in my if i give them
this software to run can they just
download it read the directions in the
readme and then run it um and how much
time do i sap from them whenever they
can't run it and these are all these
things that i think about in
productivity and what i think is that a
lot of there's a lot of companies out
there who are just saying that i'm
making this tool to make it easier to be
a developer to make you more productive
and you know what i have a very low
github user number um chris weinstock's
friend of mine i remember when i started
it we had this idea
i was i have the first i have the
distinction i'm the first person outside
of github to create a gist
like back in like 2008 like some
ridiculously long time ago
and i think about tools like github but
i think about other tools where you know
what we have all these tools i have a
toolbox full of tools but just alone
they don't make you productive because
what happens is they don't still don't
help you get to where you want to be and
i have this whole um
developer philosophy on the journey
where we we optimize so much on the
vehicle that gets us to the destination
that we forget about where we're going
like we talk about the plane that we're
flying into hawaii
but um we don't talk about where we're
staying in hawaii oh actually you know
what we we spent so much time thinking
about this plane we didn't even rent a
hotel or get a house
and i think that a lot of these tools
give you this this false sense of
security that just because you're using
said tool you know i've been watching
github for years like you have actions
amazing this new embedded development
environment i'm not using that yet
because i have a really fast local
machine but i love seeing it i love what
the possibilities are but we need to
remember that all these tools and i'm
just picking on github because you all
are my part of microsoft if it was
somebody else i'd pick on something else
but we have to realize that all these
tools don't just make us productive but
in the on their by themselves like you
know what if i have five hammers and all
i need is a screwdriver right now i'll
get it in there but i'm probably not
gonna get it back out so we need to
think about that whenever we think about
productivity so that's my that's my
short answer for that question
that's awesome and i i really like that
point and i think that also brings me on
to my very favorite question always is
what is the biggest misconception about
developer productivity that you wish
someone knew and probably leaders and
researchers um margaret can we start
with you
sure and i love this question as well
thank you for putting it to me to think
about so you know i think
one of the biggest misconceptions is
worrying too much about productivity and
not enough about experience i mean i
know in space we said developer
satisfaction and well-being is one of
the dimensions but even just shifting
that a little bit and saying that you
know looking that developer experience
is really what's important and we know
from a lot of our research that if
developers are you know feel happy and
feel secure or excited about their work
that they're going to be productive
right they're going to do good work
um so that's just one thing i wanted to
put out there
the other thing that i wanted to put out
and it's a little bit controversial and
it comes from my experience in trying to
develop tools over the years
is that we're at the cusp of a paradigm
shift of where ai is going to be used in
software development and it's super
exciting i mean i'm really excited about
the opportunities for ai at writing code
you know finding vulnerabilities in test
cases and you know identifying
bugs and also even streamlining the
build and deployment process
but ai isn't magic it's science right
and it's what people do with ai that's
going to lead to either good or bad
magic
and you know this picks up a little bit
on you know the issue of the the big
resignation or the great shuffle um
thinking about how supporting those
people in doing the really hard stuff as
as brian was saying you know
that plane how it's going to get you to
hawaii well why am i going to hawaii
anyway the really hard problem for me
when i'm going on vacation is deciding
where i'm going to go because there's
only so many choices and i have to
balance my needs with my family's needs
that's the hard part it's not really
booking the ticket or getting on the
plane
so i think that that is sort of one of
the biggest misconceptions
that if we have all of these great tools
um that that will be enough um but you
know what i feel like everybody here
we're all on the same page in this panel
we're all saying the same thing in
different things but
uh amanda
what do you think about this
the biggest misconception about
developer productivity that you wish
others knew
i i think you know i think
one of the things that that
i just see over and over and over again
in in inside of teams um but in the
industry overall
is that
there's i think there's a little bit of
kind of a gatekeeping and elitism
that actually says that only senior
engineers or engineers of a certain
caliber uh can be
you know productive engineers
and i think that you know in addition to
kind of the paradigm shift of ai that
margaret was talking about i think we're
also in the midst of a paradigm shift
when it comes to you know the
introduction of low code tools
sas services that allow you to kind of
build much more
quickly for various different kinds of
solutions you know i mean obviously like
i started in the era when a lot of
people were using visual basic six and
coming into the industry
learning how to do graphical user
interfaces and they built a heck of a
lot of you know line of business
applications that way and basically kind
of built up an industry from that and
there were a lot of people who didn't
necessarily have a formal background
in a computer science or or kind of a
degree in computer science that we're
capable of building those kinds of
solutions
and so i think you know the biggest
misconception
in
in terms of developer productivity and i
would say just kind of in terms of the
way that we think about the industry
overall is that you have to have
a four-year computer science degree from
an elite university to be able to
contribute
i think actually there are many paths to
the industry and we can see and and many
roles across the industry as well and
you know not everyone needs to be an
elite systems engineer um you know
working on operating systems kernels and
things like that
i love that uh brian all right time for
some controversy
all right so first of all
mandy says something very important here
you know there's so many paths into
computing and you know what one day i
might get a degree in something i don't
know
but right now i'm busy working and
solving problems so you know
the fact that i that my parents couldn't
afford a computer science degree and my
school didn't let me know that there was
other avenues and you know i'm just busy
getting paid right now
um i put that to the side respect it a
hundred percent um but i am proof
positive that you can do a lot of things
if you if you figure out alternative
methods of learning
but um the the controversial thing is
that um we we
we and i'm i'm talking about the
community now i'm part of it so i have
to accept this is that we we cook terms
like developer productivity developer
experience and
what happens is people use those as
crutches for you know lack of planning
just bad ideas
poor execution poor leadership
and and in a lot of cases you know we we
talk about looking for a better
developer productivity or even better
developer um experience and what we're
really talking about is that you know
what hey your company or your business
unit or your team doesn't have a plan
and we think that the lack of output
comes from you know these developers if
they could just be more productive we
would get through this and you know what
that's not true um so that's just
another way of saying that
you know the lack of planning is usually
the cause of all these things that we're
seeing um we're kind of in some cases we
are using these productivity tools as a
crutch you know i will i will um die on
this hill that the term ci and cd should
not they're not ci cd
you know they're they're two different
things if you're integrating your
software and you're delivering deploying
or whatever your software they're not
the same thing die on this hill i think
nicole knows this i think i've actually
a little sidebar i was at the concert i
was at a conference the last in-person
conference i went to at the beginning of
2019 nicole was there and i actually
told the developer the designers that
people came up that term like you know i
just don't agree
but
really what i'm saying here is that we
need to think about
it's not just developer productivity
developer experience or developer
whatever or even 8i really what it is is
that we need to take a lot of things and
we need to combine them together and we
need to we really need to use the best
tool for the best for the problem at
hand and what happens is that um you
know someone's going to hear this and
they're going to say oh wow you know dr
nicole and i'm assuming your doctor's
story too that's just my assumption but
i'm i'm sure that's where we are all
right they say all these great things
and you know what space is amazing i
actually share it with everyone i i see
i love it there's a book your accelerate
book is on right on the wall behind me
right now
but i want to say that you realize that
they're just giving you tools to make
you better they're not telling you how
to be better you know who can tell you
how to be better you
or your team
and if you're looking for those answers
externally you're going to fail and
really what what what's going to come
from externally are things that aren't
important to your business like um if
you make widgets you know if you want to
make widgets faster because you know how
to make widgets productivity is going to
help you but if you can't figure out how
to make a widget you know all these
tools
everything is just going to be another
burden and it's actually going to make
you slower and then you're just going to
say that things just don't work and you
know what you can turn this around and
if you think about it after this call
look at the word kubernetes and why
people do not like it this is the reason
why because they don't understand
they're trying to use it as a as a
crutch for something broken in their
organization or their practice
and that's my controversial date
i love it
um
if it's okay i have
two favorite misconceptions and one is
going to be a little controversial so i
think brian bryan may be on my train
um
one is that
everyone thinks it's gonna be a tool
it's gonna fix your thing it's never a
tool
uh check is easy people are hard and in
general my the huge misconception that i
always see around productivity is that
you need to use a tool to fix your
problem and that talking to people is
going to slow you down and
so often
we see that
talking to other people will actually
speed you up because they can give you
the context they can tell you it's going
to fix things
one-on-ones you're not your enemy
[Laughter]
documentation is not your enemy good
documentation talking to people
having design reviews and design
meetings this is a wonderful wonderful
thing
um and i think it's
disregarded at everyone's peril so
that's my
first misconception
um
[Music]
my second big misconception i think is
maybe a little controversial is that um
and with a slight disclaimer but
um
you don't need an assessment
you don't need numbers you don't need a
benchmark it doesn't matter nobody cares
and people are gonna be like the cult
from you yes absolutely for me nobody
cares no one needs the number it's fine
i
everyone wants a number everyone wants a
benchmark everyone wants to compare
if that's what you really need is some
kind of carrot or some kind of stick to
get better
i guess that's fine
use what works for you
also
it kind of doesn't matter if you
you just need to get better
it just needs to get better
you just need to figure out what like
brian was saying you just need to figure
out what's holding you back
and being better than somebody or being
worse than somebody is not what's
holding you back
fixing the broken things
are really what is holding you back
you don't need
all related you don't need a thousand
metrics to tell you what's broken you
could prob
walking down the hall and talking to
someone about what's broken in their
software
or broken in their experience or broken
in something will probably tell you what
you can fix
you don't need the most perfect
dashboard
grafana something
to tell you what's broken
you can just fix things it will be fine
you don't need the perfect assessment
just fix things
everything's fine
and i think with that nicole like one of
the things that's um
that that brings up for me is almost
that sometimes metrics can be harmful
um you know i think about code coverage
and kind of the damage that code
coverage has caused it's been helpful in
many ways because it certainly allows
you to like you know look at at the
the how much coverage your tests have
for the tests that you're for the code
that you're delivering
but it's also one of those numbers that
can be totally gained and you can end up
investing a huge amount in test
infrastructure that's also hard to
maintain and becomes flaky over time and
so you can end up getting kind of very
driven
uh by the metrics in a really negative
way that actually hurts productivity
over time
i love that you bring this up right oh
sorry no i'm just going to agree i mean
i think about that um i i actually do
advocate run coverage on your local
machine just to make sure that you you
tested what you thought you added but
and at the at the macro level it doesn't
really do anything for you
yeah and and so much of this is about
culture too right so
i back when i was with dora we did
assessments we offered numbers it's f
there are there are quick check tools
that many people find
i will say
useful or insightful
it was always really
interesting
to see how people would react
some teams
really wanted to be in the high or the
elite group because then it meant
they could check out and they were done
peace out
cool
other folks leaders were actually
concerned because if they were elite
event
there wasn't anywhere else to go
other folks
would check in and they would be elite
and they didn't care they'd be like cool
okay what's next still
the best most innovative organizations
would sometimes use as a check but they
would still
want to double down and find out what
needed improved so it's almost like the
thing where they say flip a coin
and it doesn't matter where it lands it
depends how you react to the answer what
really matters is how you react to the
answer do you still really want to drive
improvement
or is this your excuse to check out and
be done
and i think that's also like you know
it's really easy to do the thing that's
in front of you
the named thing fixing a bug
improving your code coverage whatever it
is that's easy it's the things that
brian was talking about earlier in terms
of you know
driving alignment on where you're
heading
that's actually the hard work
okay
next question
where do you think the future of
development is headed
i can jump in on that one if you like um
so could i change the question a little
bit
of course
to be about where do you think the
future of effective development is
headed you know the the companies that
are doing well
um because i think that that's a a nicer
question to answer
um i i think we've all been touching on
this a little bit the the companies that
are doing really well i think recognize
that their main asset is not the code
right that is developed but rather it's
the developers that hold the ideas the
theories about what the code is doing
the representation of the those ideas in
their head peter nauer talked about this
back in 1984
and thinking about that um nicole i love
that you mentioned about don't use
metrics talk to people yay qualitative
research when we did ask developers what
made them feel developed uh productive
94 of them said 94 of them said writing
code but 92 and 90 of them said it was
talking to other people and learning
something new so making them feel
empowered get recognizing that what they
were doing had impact in terms of that
other people cared about their work or
that they could help other people and
that they could learn to do better work
in the future so my hope is that the
future of development in a more
effective environment is thinking about
how to empower the software engineer how
to support them as they are connected
with their team but also their
communities and their users and help
them be responsible
and to feel responsible because today's
generation they care about human values
they care about the software that
they're writing and in today's world
software developers they have that power
to switch from company to company if
they don't feel that what they're doing
is the right thing and if they're not
themselves learning themselves right and
and contributing so that's just one take
on it
i like that amanda
that's a it's a tough question i mean i
think you know i did an intern talk
about three years ago
and uh it was kind of like well how
would the internship of 2025 look
different right
and
and you know this was before a bunch of
stuff that we had we had been working on
kind of get got released
but you know i think in that era you
still had to spend a day and a half to
set up your dev box
you know this was three years ago you
still had to
you know i think there's there's a very
challenging experience when you're a
newbie at any team where you asking for
help is really
intimidating
and especially when a lot of people now
are are starting new jobs or starting
their first job
from their home office and never having
the opportunity to actually learn from a
mentor that's sitting next to them how
do they actually get that support for
them to be successful
and so
and then margaret also talked about kind
of the introduction of of ai as a way to
kind of assist uh developers
to write the code that they need to
write and to learn from you know the
either what their the code that their
team had previously written or learned
from what the community has written in
the past
to figure out kind of what's the what's
the kind of code they need to be able to
write and so what i what i envision and
what i'd like to see happen is that you
know
we have developer environments that
where the standard is that you can
actually contribute meaningfully to the
code base uh that that the
infrastructure of setting up your dev
box
is not getting in the way
of you being able to contribute to that
code base that the knowledge base that's
established as
in terms of how the code is actually
being written
is also codified and captured as a part
of the code itself and so you have you
know a way to be able to look at uh the
code with annotations and other things
like that so that you can actually see
what are the conversations that happened
that led us to this decision or in which
context was this decision made or you
know what were the bugs or incidents
that led us to change this this
dimension of the code because you know
everybody knows that developers
really don't like to take the time to
comment the code and that's one of the
big problems that we have in the code
basis that we're building overall
and then also just just the idea of like
they're needing to be written down best
practices i think the opportunity that
we have with uh with ai
is to actually be able to derive what
the best practices are and to be able to
learn from other code examples uh as to
why that is a best practice
without having to have you know as much
documentation written so that everybody
understands why i'm not saying that
documentation isn't still necessary it
absolutely is you know at the end of the
day
this is all about human computer
interfaces and a programmer
has to be able to reason about the
program that they're writing
and so you know that the documentation
really helps them reason about it but in
terms of making sure that they're
implementing best practices
and things like that i think that's
where artificial intelligence can really
that's help
right
well are you all just blowing my mind
right now um you know i don't look it in
the face but i have been writing code
for money for over 25 years um i have a
20 year old daughter people don't
believe that either and you know what
this whole ai thing just blows my mind
nope nope nope nope
nope nope um but actually
cool yeah very cool i'm gonna keep on
investigating but nope uh but you know i
think about um
i think about these things and and and i
just wanna i don't know what the what
the makeup of the people watching this
video are going to be but i just want to
as a you know as an old-school developer
um who who's been through the ups and
downs i i just wanted to share just a
couple of things is that you know we
think about developer productivity and
experience i think that's good um like
like nicole says you know it's more
important about where you end up not the
metric
sometimes you need metrics to get there
but sometimes you don't to get started
it's like if you if you've ever played a
game of spades first hand bids itself
we're not going to even we're not going
to talk about points on the first hand
but the thing one thing i remember is is
that
code is only the output of your actions
at a given time um don't get attached to
it
it's gonna go away um amanda mentioned
something like db6 back in the day i bet
you aren't running that in production
right now it's gonna go away um java 17
just came out and i know people are
still running java 8 stop you're running
java 11. stop you know there's there's
better options out there so remember
that productivity
overall isn't just a tool it's a mindset
as nicole and margaret actually put out
that really that what we're trying to do
is figure out the the best way to create
solutions to problems that we have with
software in the least amount of time
sometimes your code sometimes you just
punt on and say you know what it'll just
be easier if someone just wrote that
number in rather than us trying to
figure it out
but remember that remember that
productivity and experience aren't about
the tooling they're about what happens
afterwards because that's what we're
optimizing for if you work for a company
for better for worse you know what we're
trying to figure out how to build
software for the cheapest amount of
money with the least amount of people
um that will bring in the greatest
amount of revenue you know what um
that's that's what it comes down to you
have feelings about it but these these
tools can help you feel better these
tools will make you feel not like not so
much of a robot that you don't have to
repeat yourself that you don't have to
know everything
and if we keep on if we keep looking at
the world is constantly moving we need
to continue investing into our craft our
art and our science and just magic
sometimes because that's what computers
are
uh that we realize that the people
thinking about this um these problems
whether they be researchers or people
who are actually just on the front lines
we need this constant yin and yang we
need both type of inputs because this is
how we go from
back in the 70s where it was a lot of
assembler a lot of um old school lisp to
now where we're talking about low code
and no code seriously it's not like the
4gls where we were just like oh look at
this nope that didn't work we're
actually thinking about this seriously
and you know what that github ai thing
that's pretty cool don't get me wrong
it's cool i have not tried it because
i don't know just
it's like saying candyman or something
and i figure if i say it too many times
my computer is going to attack me but um
i really just think that you know
we need to think about these things and
and realize that we're only at a level
there are there's like unlimited levels
and we're always trying to level up to
the next one
so just keep in mind that we need to
find better ways to do what we're doing
whether it's research or actual practice
and we need to continue doing this and
that's just how it should be
so i'm off my soapbox now thank you
no thank you i'm super excited about
the future and what it holds and i'm
with you brian i started on mainframe so
i've been around i was a developer and i
love the points about
making
development more accessible right we
have low code we have no code how do we
make this easier to read and more
accessible so that
when there isn't as much documentation
it's fine but yes how do we leverage
additional tools to help provide that
documentation
i want to thank all of our panelists for
being here with us today um i hope
everyone has enjoyed the panel and i
hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference thanks everyone
thank you thanks everybody